kca's fashion Dominique tell me about
this beautiful
yeah Madison guest styled me and I love
it
can you tell me a secret about this look
uh a secret about this look did it come
together at midnight last night are
there pockets are there snacks there's
no snacks there's no I don't have any
secrets I mean no just thank you you're
a busy Queen this year let's talk swarm
first I hear it's dark I hear it's sexy
I hear it's scary what can you tease it
is also comedic and I think what people
are uh thinking it's one thing but I
find when they see it it'll be
completely different than what we
thought I thought every episode is going
to keep you on your toes and one and
more yes okay you know I I've been
reading a little bit about it online
because I'm so I'm so intrigued by it is
it Loosely based on Beyonce uh no it's
not it's not Loosely based on Beyonce
it's a amalgamation of of different
celebrities and our current climate
being kind of uh intense about our love
for celebrities and everybody loves
Beyonce so it's easy to to correlate the
two but I I think if you're going to see
that it takes his own world in its own
Journey
you know it's so fun to see your
friendship with Chloe Bailey I love you
your fellow co-star have you gotten to
hear the album are you gonna go see her
on tour I'm definitely gonna go see her
on tour she promised that she would take
me to not only hard to a but different
tour so we can go together because I
need to know what's going on in the
music industry a little bit better
I know you're the road so you've not
only got swarm you've also got
Transformers what has it been like
having the attention on you and the
Billboards everywhere oh the Billboards
are extraordinary we haven't got any
Transformers Billboards yet but I know
that's coming really soon you saw it
soon so that's really cool and I'm super
excited to to be together with Anthony
Ramos we're both from Brooklyn our
characters are from Brooklyn so yeah
it's sweet what is scarier the drama on
Swarm or running from the uh the crazy
monsters in Transformers
swarm be
[Music]
back to me yeah what's your biggest goal
for 2023
um to be like I give every word every
year a word and this one is my light
year and I want to be light about the
things that always made me feel so heavy
and and to be positive and give love and
bring joy
thank you so much nice to meet you so
much fun thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
foreign